three seconds
just three seconds is what it takes and
it is enough to get millions of people
hyped up on how good this movie is going
to be
and if you look at kong's background it
kind of looks like he is on a ship
which explains why godzilla is coming
through the water but that is just many
of the monsterverse fans theories
but come the thing about it the teaser
released on comic con 2019 showed both
of them
before a fight on top of an aircraft
carrier which means
it might be true we want to do a full
breakdown of this teaser but there's
only three seconds of it
other than godzilla being covered in
more jagged and sharp spikes
swimming under the ocean there's only
one other thing that has aroused
everyone's curiosity
and that is the metal collar on gong's
neck
what is it well we have three possible
explanations for what it might be and
either of these three theories would be
true
so bear with us as we might get a 33
success rate this time
number one chain caller so the first
theory on this list is that we have gong
china by monarch or some other
international organization
and since we can see quite a few ships
in the background
it most definitely means that there
would be the us military being involved
in some way with this
so as we have seen in the 1962 king kong
vs godzilla movie the giant ape was
dropped to sleep on faroe island
and transported by ship to the mainland
to fight against the g-man
so in this next monster verse film i'm
guessing that there would be some kind
of similar situation that kong gets
himself in
which would allow monarch or some other
group to chain him up and transport him
towards the big battle
in this upcoming movie kong would be far
bigger than his 104 ft height in 1973
and 200 feet height of the comics in the
birth of gong
so how in the world would humanity hope
to contain or even restrict
this movements with chains but as you
can see the collar is present on the
neck
but there are no chains does it mean
that kong woke up and took them off with
ease
maybe since kong is a terrestrial titan
he would have continued to stay on board
the ship though
if the convoy was still in the high seas
his lack of
swimming skills might have indirectly
trapped him on board one of the ships
and he knows it number two mind control
device
the second theory is a bit far-fetched
but it does have a bit of a background
godzilla and the other touhou kaiju have
all fallen prey to an alien racist mind
control
and in this state their only goal is to
complete destruction of humanity
the zillions and the kailax have quite
often did not utilize other giant
monsters to fight against humanity
and later against godzilla therefore if
we take a look at kong's neck piece it
might be one of these devices that allow
the organization
to take him away from skull island and
fight godzilla or another one of the
other titans
a similar thought arises when we come to
think about it even the toy mega
godzilla hints that godzilla would be
having a red
contraption on his back and this might
mean that there's some big
organization would have had the daunting
task towards taming the big
g with some armor that also restricts
his power-ups and controls his mind
so keeping that in mind it isn't that
far off to assume that even kong would
fall into the strap
hence the neck collar might actually be
a mind controlling machine
number three the neck taser as seen in
the movie thor ragnarok the mighty god
thor had
a small taser on his neck to make him
well
behave and fight against the hulk so
would this be the most diverse version
of a taser on the neck of kong
and of course it draws a couple of
parallel lines between gvk and ragnarok
in the former kong and godzilla are both
rivals and good guys
so even in the mcu thor and the hulk are
rivals and also good guys
anyway getting back to the color it
might be a restrictive neck taser that
shoots out sudden shocks if you make a
rash move
zapping him in line like an obedient
warrior of course this would be the most
interesting theory
out of the three as this one would
explain a lot as to why godzilla would
fight kong
imagine an organization managing to
capture kong how would they even manage
to keep kong in their control
this 350 feet plus tall ape would have
no problem ripping the military a new
one
without breaking a sweat if not for the
vast ocean expanse and his lack of
swimming skills
so what happens if he was ever to make
landfall humanity must have plan b
to keep kong under their control and
eventually directing him to fight the
other titans and that have destroyed
their cities
so a neck taser would do the trick
so yeah that's about it for this video
on the three theories explaining the
metal color on king kong's neck
leave a like if you like this and
subscribe for more monster verse videos
and also smash that notification bell
for regular updates
and if you have your own theories do put
them down in the comments section below
we're all hoping that the trailer would
be released this 25th december
as it would coincide with the release of
wonder woman
84 in theaters and but that's just
our hopes and dreams take care fam